hey everybody its Charlie this is gonna
be my non-spoilery mission impossible'
fallout review if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos we still got a whole
bunch of stuff happening this summer the
subtitle of the movie fallout refers to
the fallout from the events of the
previous film because the Solomon Lane
character is back but also literally
fallout as a nuclear fallout from
weapons having to do with the events of
the last film the films were connected
in a way that Mission Impossible movies
haven't really been in the past it used
to be more like James Bond continuity
where it was the same characters and the
events were loosely connected and it was
just like this is what the missions
going to be this time but now it's
acting more like a traditional sequel
where you have the events of the
previous film directly influencing the
plot of the next film but the real
subtitle we should just start calling
these movies is a Tom Cruise destroying
his body for our entertainment that's
really the challenge there's two real
important conversations that you have
when you talk about Mission Impossible
films one were the stunt school were
they bigger better than the last film
and to how well does it work as a
Mission Impossible film as opposed to
just a general action film because it's
not like Fast and the Furious even
Christopher McQuarrie the director who
was amazing on this film in the last
film made a joke about how the air bus
scene at the beginning of rogue nation
at one point in the development stage
looked exactly like the plot of Fast &
Furious 6 with that never ending runway
so one of the tropes of a Mission
Impossible film that makes it mission
impossible is the story of how things
always go wrong and how the team works
together to make it right so it would be
weird if they made a really awesome plan
and then it didn't go completely off the
rails one of the things this film does
really well is play on the tropes of the
earlier Mission Impossible films if
you're a longtime fan of the franchise
you'll recognize Easter eggs and moments
going all the way back to the first film
it won't ruin it if you don't remember
the plot of those earlier films but it
does kind of enhance the viewing
experience so I would recommend
revisiting the first film at some point
the film's now are so different from
what they used to be I would argue that
modern Mission Impossible films really
began with rogue nation Mission
Impossible 3 was meant to be sort of a
hard reboot of the series with the way
it worked in the way they use the care
characters and how they plotted it out
but I think ghost Protocol was probably
the first film to successfully
accomplish that and then they perfected
the model with road nation and now it's
even better with fallout so I don't want
to say that it's the best Mission
Impossible film but it's definitely one
of my favorite if not the favorite my
last favorite was rogue nation but I do
think that fallout does a better job of
having the team work together which is
one of the complaints about some of the
earlier films we're like you do have
Luthor's character but he's on the other
side of the planet so he's not really
working with the team in the way that
you would expect him to they do a good
job of making Tom Cruise's Ethan Hunt
character feel like an outsider even
though they kind of fixed the IMF
problem in the last movie part of the
plot of rogue nation is is that they
were putting the entire IMF on trial
they kind of solved that problem but
Mission Impossible films work best when
Ethan feels like he's in the wrong even
though he's trying to do the right thing
like I said it's all about having a
really awesome plan that totally goes
off the rails for a little while before
he saves the day with some crazy twist
by the end so even though the IMF is a
good standing you never really feel like
the government itself as an organization
has Ethan hunts back the way that you
would want them to but again into some
of the other characters they're really
like couple important characters that
you need to talk about with this film
one is Henry Cavill the super stache
tore it up Henry Cavill has some really
great performances during Man of Steel
but this just proves that he can
actually be a really good actor outside
of the DC Universe so he has talked a
lot about teaming up with Tom Cruise and
Christopher McQuarrie for other future
films that gets mostly into like them
doing another Man of Steel movie or even
Tom Cruise and Christopher McQuarrie
teaming up for Green Lantern Corps you
may hear some rumors about that this
weekend because people are like are you
all going to work together again because
then working together on fallout went so
well Christopher McQuarrie is such a
great director and a writer at the same
time and Tom Cruise is so good at what
he does and Henry Cavill is just
chomping at the bit to be in other good
movies there's a possibility that they
could team up for another DC film at
some point in the future but that's
still a bit up in the air so we can talk
about that if they make any official
announcements Henry Cavill knows what it
would be like we you know we had a lot
of time hanging out unsaid and and
Henry's a huge fan of Superman and I
can't help but
but talk story with people so he told me
his take on men on Superman and I
thought it was really great and I gave
him my two cents the tweet you're
referring to if somebody asked would you
do it and I said hey they know where to
find me nobody's asked but you know so
we can't say enough about how
christopher mcquarrie makes good use of
henry cavill and Embree loading his guns
they've been using that to market the
film all over the world for the past
couple of months this only the beginning
and of course Rebecca Ferguson was the
film's secret weapon during rogue nation
she's probably the best new addition to
the franchise she kills it during
Fallout figuratively and literally I
hope they never get rid of her I'm
actually excited to see her do other big
movies like this because she wasn't that
big of an actress before they found her
for rogue nation she was doing a bunch
of other smaller films so rogue nation
really was like her first big huge film
notably absent of course is Hawkeye
which is a recurring theme this year
this is like the year Jeremy Renner
isn't in the big movies that he was just
in a little while ago the only reason
why he's not around though is because he
was booked filming Avengers 4 while they
were filming this movie so his character
is still around he'll probably come back
for Mission Impossible 7
pretty sure they're gonna make it the
critical reception the box office for
this is doing so well that of course
they're going to make another one
like I said they made great use of Ving
Rhames character he gives the series a
nice sense of continuity that you don't
get just because there's not a whole lot
of people left over from that original
Mission Impossible film Simon Pegg was
great again I've always been a big fan
of his character in this franchise his
whole thing after his first Mission
Impossible film several years ago was
that he did not want to be that Ned lead
Spider Man homecoming man in the chair
like he actually wanted to get out and
get dirty like the other characters so I
should also say they do find an
interesting way of invoking Michelle
Monaghan's character too they do a
really good job of wrapping her arc up
with Ethan because they've been this
thing with the last couple of films like
what are they gonna do with her
character going forward is she gonna
continue to be part of the franchise I
think they left the franchise in a place
where they can
pick up in the next film without having
to completely be tied to what happened
in these last two films like II can go
back to James bond-style where they just
have another mission to accomplish and
they don't have to explain where a lot
of these other side characters are there
was another new character played by
Vanessa Kirby I can't really say who she
is without getting into spoilers but she
was another secret weapon to the film
great addition they do a really good job
of finding really badass women to bring
into this franchise what you guys have a
chance to see it though let me know what
you thought of it in the comments below
careful to use spoiler tags if you want
to get really specific because this is
meant to be a non-spoilery review but
just a reminder if you do have time
re-watch that first film like I said you
know no spoilers it won't ruin your
enjoyment of the film if you never saw
it or you don't remember what the plot
is but there are a couple big tropes
characters things that they borrow from
the plot of that movie that are
important during fallout so I have to
say I am completely blown away with how
well this film worked when we heard
about all the drama with Justice League
in the super stache last year you expect
the worst like oh how could they do this
but this Mission Impossible movie turned
out really awesome so I was pleasantly
surprised so definitely go check it out
this weekend when you get the chance but
there'll be a whole bunch more
comic-book stuff coming up while you
wait for everything click here for all
my Comic Con trailers and click here for
brand new Avengers 4 thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
you